okay so Thor 11 Thunder is gonna show a
Christian going after the Gods like
Passion of the Christ too Jesus returns
the new trailer for the film has just
dropped and in it we see Gore the god
butcher AKA gautamort basing off against
the God of Thunder before you could even
say let's see Paul Allen's goal the guy
left a terrifying impression that
definitely got all those bad feelings
out my head that I might have had from
the toilex there's a lot riding on
Christian shoulders and throughout this
video we're going to be talking about
why Gore is so loved in the comic book
Kingdom we'll also be going over the
character's backstory from The Source
material talking about what his mission
is and also giving our theories on what
could be happening in the movie so sit
back shut up and make sure you hit that
Thumbs Up Button along with the
Subscribe one as we do videos like this
every day and we'd love to have you as
one of the Gods of ponder at the channel
well out the way thanks for clicking
this now let's get into Gore the god
butcher
ones who Gods care about
is themselves
is My Vow
oh God shall die okay so the thing
that's probably gonna strike you first
about Gore in this new trailer is the
black and white monochrome way that he
appears seeming like a vampire Gaul
presents a striking image of white
against the black darkness that
surrounds him this pulls heavily from
the comics and in those when we saw
gorda's most powerful he was surrounded
in swashes of thick black ink that
provided him with not only a cape but
also a hood now he was a far cry from
this earlier in his life and Gore came
from a harsh Wasteland where his entire
species battled with Extinction every
day the people were poor and because
they hadn't developed any real
scientific Technologies due to their
focus being on Survival they became
superstitious believing that God ruled
their fate they put their faith solely
in them and would curse the bad days as
being things that were caused by them
not worshiping hard enough it's a motif
that's often discussed in the
development of religions and he can
pretty much track through the last
thousand years when religious doctrines
were at their Peak and the economic
surroundings that caused the world to be
like that if you've ever read Frank
Herbert's due and then you'll know
there's a lot of talk in that about how
the quiz at tararatch manipulated the
people of Iraqis by taking away all that
they had and then putting in place
religion so that they would follow them
I'm kind of veering off track here but
this mentality is important to bear in
mind when we talk about why Gore turned
from his people's ways in his early life
he experienced a lot of tragedy and his
mother was attacked by beasts on the
planet as she fought to buy him enough
time to escape she was highly religious
as well instilling in him this idea that
if he prayed enough that the gods would
answer but they never did Gore grew up
with this belief instilled in him
however as it was one of the last things
his mother ever said still though he
faced the harshness of reality and his
wife died in an earthquake with their
unborn child slowly his other children
starve to death as well and this pushed
him to the point of screaming to his
tribe that there were no Gods those guys
though were still highly superstitious
and thinking that there'd be a reprisal
for Gore's Outburst they banished him to
the harsh desert of the rock they'd been
cursed to exist on sanso Santo cool
saying stuff like that when I talk about
Comics anyway amongst the barren
landscape cool came across two dueling
gods that were locked in combat this was
a golden Knight and a black one that I
think was null the wiki says it's null
but I got a lot of on the last video for
saying that so we'll just say it's a
black knight but not the one from the
eternals okay let's calm down anyway the
golden god emerged Victorious but he was
badly beaten and he reached out to gore
and asked for help enraged by this he
realized that the one being that he'd
prayed to his entire life for her that
had never been there for him was asking
for the same thing back it drove Gore
wild with rage as he'd realize not only
that gods did exist but that all they
really cared about was themselves at
this point no sorry black the Black
Knight sword turned into a ball of dark
energy that wrapped around him and gave
him incredible Powers this was the necro
sword a powerful element strong enough
to kill even a god Gore struck down the
golden Knight and thus began his
Millennial on quest to kill the gods
amongst the universe us he realized that
Gods didn't care about those that
worshiped them and put their arrogance
they had to pay now Gaul went out
throughout the cosmos killing all that
he could find in 893 A.D he ran into
Thor and it was at this point that the
God of Thunder learned about him as well
the pair had many run-ins with their
first one being one of the darkest days
of Thor's life Gore managed to capture
him and he tortured him for 17 days in
order to find out how to get to Asgard
his Viking followers found him and when
Gore started laying the smackdown they
all began to pray to Thor Gore tried
showing them how useless the gods were
and why they shouldn't put their faith
in them but Thor used this moment to cut
off Gore's arm from that point onwards
he made it his life mission to get
revenge and this anger fueled him into
getting a longer than normal lifespan
believing he'd killed him Thor didn't
bother searching for him however Gore
kept going eventually though Thor came
across a planet that had all become
atheists because their gods never
answered their calls and upon going to
the heavens he found them all
slaughtered though then set up on a trip
to omnipotent city which is where he
went to the Hall of the Lost which
detailed all the gods that had gone
missing using this as a road map he
followed Gore's trail of Destruction and
the pair fought several times with a
court eventually leading him to a sort
of a sort of portal Through Time Gore
took Thor to one of the first Gods which
he killed at the beginning of all
creation in the future 900 years from
then Thor came across a version of
himself that had been battling Gore's
black Berserkers for centuries he also
came across a younger version of himself
who had been enslaved by Gore to build
his weapon the god bomb this incredibly
destructive device had the power to kill
Gods across the entire timeline so that
none would ever exist Gore also had a
new wife and child the latter of which
tormented Thor as he was enslaved Gore's
wife was eagerly awaiting until his
quest was over so that they could
finally have a life together but she
slipped up she bloody slipped up she
ended up telling Gore that in many ways
he was now a God himself and angered by
this he killed her he hid this from his
son but he found out dead and ended up
calling him the god of hypocrisy at one
point after escaping Thor and the other
versions returned to finally fight it
out with Gore but he easily beat them
however Gerson aided them and Thor ended
up grappling with the bomb in an attempt
to absorb it as it was going off guards
Across the Universe they ended up
praying to Thor to save them and
empowered by this he absorbed the blast
as well as the necro sword though ended
up beheading Gaul and he himself
seemingly died however he did return
three days later now Gore did pop up
again after being resurrected by logi
but I do think that the film will pretty
much follow his journey in the God of
Thunder they pretty much have the falaga
the Behemoth panel which is ripped right
out of the comics yeah probably follow
this but don't quote me on that yet
haven't seen the movie yet now I think
Thor will probably learn of Gore at the
beginning and then he'll set out to all
near the gods which is when he'll bump
into Zeus I can see Gore's entrance
being him showing up to murder him and
that will be where we start to learn
about his backstory also the look of
Gore has massively changed her and in
the trailer we actually see one point
where his face looks like it has tattoo
markings on it these are gone as he
steps in in the monochrome world so I'm
guessing that potentially his appearance
changes whilst the necros all corrupts
him lots of ways they can go about it
and who knows we might even end up with
at least a nod to his design in the
comics I know that's a big sticking
point for people around the character
but I'm not too bothered by it as long
as Bale delivers a good performance
which see he seems to be doing going off
this brand new look what about that's my
opinion and I'd love to hear yours so if
you want to talk about that his
backstory or what you think will happen
then comment below and let me know we
are on a competition right now giving
away three copies of the Batman on the
15th of June and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch the make you check out our
breakdown of the trailer which will be
linked on screen right now if if not
then thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul you see I'll see
you next time you take care yourself
peace